Colton's women revealed in dog years
Lucy 70 new interviews with the most
important men in our lives and a social
media scandal already it's time for
roses and Rosie you guys I just revealed
myself just like Colin's women have been
revealed and it's been revealed that one
of them said some bad crap a while ago
I'm Lauren Zima I know we didn't do a
video last week I'm so sorry I was
traveling for Newark I'll make myself
take a drink cuz I'm sorry mm-hmm
the best form of punishment anyway I was
out but now guys I am back and there is
so much to discuss this is bachelor news
you can boost please drink responsibly
and tweet responsibly let's get right
into it all first of all colton's women
revealed is being cute a profession on
Thursday Chris Harrison longtime
franchise host took to the most
enigmatic cinematic incomparable
distinguished platform of our time
Facebook to go live and reveal Colton's
30 contestants so you know The Bachelor
is like my politics it's like my
football and so I had to break down the
women by the numbers and give you guys
the stats that's that's what people do
in sports our stats who's your pick to
win your draft of things anyway so
here's what you need to know there are
of course 30 women but only two of them
are in their 30s ones 30 and
barely crack in that decade but you know
what Colton's 2627 so NBD I get it we
got to have women in his sensible age
range and that's why there are nine 23
year-olds 23 is the most prominent age
on this season let's take a drink for
the 30 substance and the drink for their
just in their 20-somethings I mean I
will say ask Chris Harrison about this
we'll get to that and he did say look we
have to pick based on the bachelor when
Ari was bachelor was a huge deal that
Becca M was only 23 but Ari is like in
his mid-thirties other important
statistical things you know we always
get the women's jobs jobs jobs jobs they
used to be jobs and other kind of fun
titles that the producers give them
sometimes but this year 27 of the women
have real jobs that are listed things
like interior designer and wow I can't
think of one that's another real job
that there is whatever there legit and
they sound like they get paychecks for
them the three not job jobs that are
listed are one a sloth a slow roll let's
drink for each one mm-hmm to a never
been kissed and three oh crap and three
a Cinderella story I don't know actually
I do I asked Chris about this and he
said when it comes to the woman who's
sloth don't mistake that for like the
sin of sloth like she's lazy it's more
about being like the animal very
slow-moving guessing we're gonna get a
night 1 joke out of this that's what's
gonna happen I'm gonna move myself back
towards what matters in my life okay he
said when it comes to the woman who's
never been kissed she's never been
kissed she's never been kissed and also
she
the at least one confirmed there might
be more but the one confirmed fellow
virgin with Colton on his season she's
never been kissed and you know sensical
II she's never had sex so I've never
been kissed and at least one virgin
there might be more out there you never
know
and with the Cinderella Chris said it's
not that she plays Cinderella at a
Disney theme park which I had hoped
because if you watch this show you know
that it is my long-lost job and my never
fulfilled desire that I never spent a
summer as a disney princess little town
he's a quiet village every day I stop
myself okay but she is a Cinderella
story like you know like um I think
that's a sports thing it's like you
Cinderella's story like what a movie
Russell Crowe is he a boxer is this
right Cinderella Man thank you JC a
Cinderella Man with a Cinderella story
like where you come up from the bottom
about you're here great other stats for
your being a fan other stats there are
at least eight women of color okay
diversity there are ten women from
California you know where people go to
pursue careers in the entertainment
industry just saying and the most
prominent names this season now let's
get to the Hanna's there are a couple of
Hanna's and a couple of Alex's and the
most important takeaway from the reveal
of the women is the number zero
oh that doesn't really make a zero
that's a zero and what's inside is
important there are zero Lauren's this
season
there's not one Lauren on the show do
you know how tired I am of accidentally
talking about myself or maybe someone
else in third person it's so confusing
my name is Lauren reporting on Lauren
Burnham and Lauren Bushnell and Lauren I
love all of them and I love my name and
their name is but it sucks
Lauren so I'm wearing finally I'll have
clarity no Lauren anyway in my opinion I
don't think you can have a show without
Lauren so those are the big
by-the-numbers takeaways on Colton's
thirty contestants by the way filming
this we filmed this on Monday December
10th and we are one month away exactly
from the season premiere on January 7th
we also learned that it will be a
three-hour three Live premiere so that's
exciting and I won't know what you guys
thought of the women the full group
photo made available the individual
photos made available you can check out
more coverage at each timeline calm the
gals and let me know what you think just
based on their pictures and quick little
BIOS alone do you have a favorite do you
have a standout are there a few that you
can see vibing with golden ok I kept
mentioning it our next Bachelor news you
can booze moment is that I interviewed
Chris Harrison just a couple of days ago
yes yes yes and we talked about Colton's
season right after he revealed the
ladies Chris really you know he's a
sound bite machine unless just cheers -
Chris Harrison because wow he teased the
season a couple big takeaways one told
me it is unconventional meaning we truly
will see things on the show that we have
never seen before now Chris always
promises most dramatic ever etc but he
says we will see conversations moments
we've never seen before in 22 seasons of
The Bachelor number two he says it's
better than he knows yes Chris said this
season The Bachelor will be better than
the last he says Colton is raw and he
really pushes the show and the team so
two big takeaways from Chris Harrison
and I had him break down the big moments
of the trailer because you guys will
remember oh that the trailer really
stood out to me especially that bit
where Colton is hugging a producer and
crying here's what Chris Harrison said
why does Colton storm off as he storming
off from the cameras what's happening I
wish I could say it wasn't because of me
but I was there I was right behind him
and I was the one that was trying to
talk to him so I guess technically it
was my fault
technically my fault but there was there
are things that led to me having to talk
to him that forced the jump yes he
addressed the fence job and it's his
fault
it's Chris Harrison's fault that's why
we need Chris Harrison around he gets
people doing crap like that scaling
fences
love it that it's like that scene is
like the Blair Witch Project of The
Bachelor it's like so dark and grainy I
love it so much I've never seen the
Blair Witch Project in this entire day I
hate scary movies so I hope that
reference is on point I think it is
anyway Chris also said that we will find
out more about why Colton is a virgin
I've asked Colton about this before back
when he was doing men tell all for
Becca's season I said you know what will
it take for you to lose your virginity
what's it kind of about and he said he
was waiting for the right heart now
Colton has stuck to that messaging but
Chris said there's more to the virginity
story and it will be revealed you had
said that Colton's reason for being a
virgin because I've asked Colton about
this before you know was it about
marriage religion and you said his
has to do with prior relationships and
experiences I just want to know how you
reacted when you found out why he's a
virgin
to me it just everything kind of fell
into place and it made a lot of sense to
me there was a religious aspect to it
and his faith had a lot to do with it
and it still does it is something that's
important to him and it means a lot as
it should but then there were other
elements that I think when you just say
oh he's 26 and I'm pretty like what like
what like he's an NFL athlete he's you
know not hard to look at I don't
understand and something was missing and
so for me I guess the best way to put it
is it fell into place because until you
know someone's whole story he just it
doesn't make sense and Chris also teased
an unconventional moment an emotional
yes we've seen emotional before but an
emotional and serious conversation
between Colton and a contestant named
Kailyn
here's that so I will say this on a
serious note with Kailyn is that she
brings out a story a personal story that
is one of the most emotional kind of
revealing conversations we've ever had
on the show we were all very much taken
aback and so was Colton and then that
kind of prompts things in Colton's life
and so it really was something kind of
different it was very different and you
know I often joke and I'm like oh it's
the most dramatic thing ever and and I
don't want to do that because it really
does a disservice to what this
conversation is about and and kudos to
both of them for for her speaking about
it Colton receiving it the right way and
then having the conversation that he did
it was it's a very memorable and
something that's gonna change kind of
the course of this entire show does it
prompt a reveal from Colton I think it
does what do you guys think it is tweet
me and let me know Kris said a sincere
serious intense convo between Colton and
Kailyn that prompts big reveals from
both of them it's not to be taken
lightly I'm interested I'm intrigued I
would love for the show as much as I
love it for what it is would love for it
to kind of take a bit of a turn and
ground itself in some intense
reality where issues are addressed that
people have because the show is in many
ways quite a psychological process so
I'd like to see something different and
deep would you like to or do you just
want to keep it light and easy and
breezy and Colton girl send it it there
anyway so next up oh my god
more bachelor news you can booze it's a
social media scandal already and we
haven't even had the premiere yet guys
this is like becoming a thing remember
on Beca season Garrett had that
Instagram scandal before her season
really got going and now a contestant
named Tracy shap off ship off I'm clear
apparently some old posts on social
media have been dug up from her and she
has taken to Instagram to apologize she
says I want to start by expressing my
sincerest apologies for the extremely
hurtful words that I said many years ago
I'm so sorry for those who I've offended
I am beyond mortified that I ever had
those thoughts and then proceeded to
express them by no means does this
reflect the person who I am today you
know what tell me what you guys think of
this I have to say I give Tracy credit
that she apologized right away I
remember we hadn't heard from Garrett
for a minute there when his stuff was
happening Tracy took to Instagram right
away released that apology and I like
that she just owned it and said I can't
believe I had those thoughts I shouldn't
have had those thoughts and she says
they're not who she is today we're gonna
have to see what happens when the season
premieres but let me know what you think
of Tracy's apology anyhoo by the way I
don't know I couldn't find anywhere what
exactly she said guys so I'm just owning
that I haven't seen what she said I
couldn't find it let me know if you do
it's just becoming like a merely social
media scandal at this point you know hey
Garrett Garrett Tracy ship off next up
in big bachelor news you can booze it's
the bachelor himself Golden Underwood
et always interviews the lead at their
first ever photo shoot for their
bachelor bachelorette promos and this
interview is done before they start
filming but we asked them all about
their intentions it's kept under wraps
until we are able to reveal it and now
we can I can give you my interview with
Colton here's what Colton said about the
big question will he lose his virginity
on the show I'm waiting for someone that
has the right heart I'm waiting for to
be madly in love with somebody so if
that happens by the time fantasy suites
comes around so be it so it's not about
waiting for marriage for you it's just
about waiting for that right person yeah
it's about finding finding the person
that's for me and that's gonna you know
obviously share a very special moment
Colton also address the critics the
naysayers because I know that you know
they're out there and some of them are
you and that's okay we're all entitled
to our own opinions as long as those
opinions are backed up at justification
I don't like opinions where people can't
explain themselves
I must admit so here's what Colton said
to people who say that he is not ready
to find a wife and criticize him as a
bachelor I'm not perfect
and I also think that you know it's so
important to really continue to grow and
to continue to push yourself and I know
through the Bachelorette and through
bachelor in paradise I've grown as a
person and I've really sort of came into
my own so you know I don't pay attention
to it too much because I'm just focused
on finding my wife and you know being
here
in the moment okay what do you guys
think of Colton's responses are you
getting on weirder than meeting the
bachelor were you already on borders and
being The Bachelor all signs point to
this being a good season guys Chris made
me excited about it
I think Colton's a sweetie and I think
there's a lot of depth there so let's
dive in well just an excuse for me to
sing a star is born
[Music]
multiple Golden Globe in Grammy
nominations Congrats to our bachelor
Bradley Cooper and our Bachelorette Lady
gaga
she's engaged while she walked down the
aisle [ __ ] anyway last step in bachelor
news you can booze where is Colton well
he's skiing this is just a social media
update guys golden Underwood has gotten
more and more out there with his social
media posts and he went to Steamboat
Springs Colorado if you're there if you
saw him let me know tweet me what was up
with him with blank his former
Bachelorette co-star and pal I love that
Colton and Blake are hanging out Blake
also hanging out with Ben you know they
all live in Denver and as Ben told us we
are gonna see him on Colton season
Denver's really become sort of like
bachelor boy hub
you know Dallas is another bachelor hope
you got Jojo Jordan there and Rachel and
Ryan there and some other people in
Nashville and you got Carly and Evan
they're Kaitlyn and Shawn that's dark
let's not end on a dark note everybody
this has been bachelor news you can
booze thanks to roses and Rose a
including our exclusive moments with
Colton Underwood and Chris Harrison
arguably the two most important men in
my life for the next six months or so I
know it shouldn't even say arguably they
just start by just are except for Jessie
[Music]
all right thank you all so much for
watching and for being here and please
leave your comments and questions I love
to talk to you about to the bachelor and
all the latest what do you think will
happen on golden season what is the big
emotional conversation what is Colton's
reasoning for being a virgin how excited
are you scaling one to town I met like a
72 I meant like five Golden Globe
nominations for Bradley Cooper and Linda
gaga stars born I'm a tab like a whole
bottle of wine that fits in this great
wine glass and I'm going to continue use
and I'm glad you guys liked it and also
some people commented and wondered if I
keep my wine shield I do keep it chill
just because it's here on the floor
doesn't mean that it's don't show that
label doesn't mean that it isn't shield
it's been in the refrigerator I just
bring it out here and I have it for
convenience's sake bye
[Music]